I play a mean game of Scrabble I'm very
good at Jeopardy
and I love to cook I also make a really
solid bolognese sauce Meghan Markle
opens up about life at home with Prince
Harry and their two kiddos
three-year-old Archie and one-year-old
lillibet and honestly it's super
relatable
let's talk about this for a second The
Duchess of Sussex sits down for a new
interview with variety and gives fans a
little insight into how she and her
hubby spend their down time including
the shows they binge watch together if
we do turn on the TV which is fairly
rare I think we're like most people
where you just do endless endless
endless searching until you get so tired
of searching you don't watch anything
Tale As Old As Time there's some
incredible shows on at the moment and I
think really watching great storytelling
there's nothing like it so I would say
White Lotus was pretty good example of
that welcome to the White Lotus thank
you how was your journey here
long and sure Meg says she makes a solid
Bolognese but the lovebirds also love
fast food
they often stop at the In-N-Out Burger
Bar much to the astonishment of the
staff who served them and anyone that
knows Prince Harry knows that he loves a
good burger quote my husband's favorite
is in and out there's one at the halfway
point between LA and our neck of the
woods it's really fun to go through the
drive-through and surprise them they
know our order of course Harry and Megan
move to Montecito California in 2020 and
officially stepped down as senior
members of the royal family in 2021 it
is of course a beautiful home it's a
forever home and somewhere where they'll
lay their roots and I think moving
slightly out of the city and somewhere
where other celebrities were able to
enjoy privacy they're really able to now
create a safe space to raise Archie away
from prying eyes and speaking of Archie
Meg says he's got his own favorite shows
too and buckle your seat belts literally
because it's giving Miss Frizzle vibes
he's getting into more throwback shows
like Magic School Bus who would have
thought he thinks it's great so that's
been pretty fun to sort of see it again
through his eyes I've become that Mom
where I'm like sitting around with
friends and I start seeing like
Tyrannosaurus that's the chorus Tyrant I
was like what am I singing oh my gosh
I'm singing storybooks I'm singing
storybooks I am not singing Beyonce in
that moment I'm singing StoryBots
[Music]
not bad Meg and while the former suit
star confirms she's done with acting she
says she won't discourage her kids from
working in entertainment quote when you
become a parent you genuinely want your
kids to find the things that bring them
complete joy and according to Megan it's
her kids who are giving her complete Joy
these days
part of what I find a lot of strength or
faith in
looking at my kids I know it sounds so
cheesy but my gosh it's the most
perspective building thing and also I
think recognizing that
everything is temporary to really just
enjoy what time we have here what we're
doing with that time and at least open
the door for really meaningful
conversation because I think once you
turn meaningful conversation into action
game changer
[Music]